right this virus has reshaped our entire
word creating a pandemic which is forces
to change our routines and rethink our
immediate future Sports is trying to get
back into our lives but positive tests
for Kobe 19 keep throwing us for a loss
over at UNLV a simple hash tag has
organically exploded on social media and
if enough he'd the hash tag there may be
color sports this fall have you ever met
somebody who's created a hashtag that
has grown from coast to coast in a
matter of days UNL B's athletic director
Desiree Reed Francois is that person she
was driving by Allegiant Stadium with
her teenage son who asked her if there
would be fall sports and I said well
Jackson we're gonna play if we can play
it safely and it's critically important
that we all wear our masks from this
tweet face masks for fall sports a
hashtag movement was hatched
universities across the country joined
in from Buffalo to Central Florida Penn
State Georgia Tech TCU all over the West
Boise State Washington State Arizona
State and the list goes on and on UN are
joining the movement the main sign in
every state should read wear masks
especially if you're hoping to sit in a
stadium my student-athletes our coaches
and all of our staff are working so hard
they're dying to play and if it means
wearing a mask we'll do it
stats don't lie just like masks saves
lives so thanks to you an obese athletic
director a simple social media tweet
might simply help fans get back in the
stands this fall we really want to play
fall sports and a face masks help us get
there that's what we're going to do all
right we'll see what happens coach of
the aces